more than 15 pounds what is that 56 000
seating capacity
40 thousand 40 000 tickets already sold
in australia for whitaker versus out of
sonia holy [ __ ] oh my goodness
october 6th in the [ __ ] marvel
stadium i like a
marvel comic stadium dude ronda rousey
home
holds the record does it dude they just
said that
oh wow yeah yeah oh wow that was the
last attendance record for mma
in australia i remember being there that
was crazy you think rhonda will ever
come back
nope never no i don't think she wants to
i think rhonda's a strong woman you know
she decides she's done she's done she's
going to move on
i don't think she wanted to you know to
keep doing it
i just think you know i think making
money off i think
when she came back and fought amanda and
then amanda knocked her out
um that must have like really [ __ ] her
up
mentally but like now looking back
like amanda's the she [ __ ] up cyborg
like yeah she would have [ __ ] up
anybody so
i'm thinking that ronda's feels a little
bit better about that amanda fight
right maybe yeah she got knocked out by
holly before that though and they got
starched by amanda
yeah but then amanda just knocked out
holly with a [ __ ] but still even for
sure
even today but they weren't competitive
even today still
even today if the fight's on the ground
you got to give it to rhonda rhonda i'm
still better than you i don't know about
that with amanda
amanda
owned everybody on the ground with
armbars but she's a had a very
singular attack arm bars it was all
armed i'm just saying she wasn't
fighting great competition i'm just
saying if she just
focused on her judo and and her arm bars
and and and didn't try to be a striker
um
you think she'd be like a khabib now i
think if she went to america
you lose a couple everyone loses you
just you lose you come back everyone
loses and they come back you know dude i
think rhonda would still be in the mix
100 she would have to separate and move
to a real camp
she would have to train with real
trainers like a real group of killers
grappling trainers wrestling trainers
make sure she's got the best sparring
partners and
more important striking coach a real
mind a real
like uh like uh for us a hobby like
someone like that
or you know mike brown or you know
with duke roof or someone top of the
food chain person
matt um matt hume right a top of the
food chain
coach why would she just she wouldn't
that's why i'm not saying she's killing
it in wwe she wants that she's kids
this was crazy [ __ ] watching stipe just
knock out dc it was crazy dude
those curtis blades on now dude uh
stipe how much money is rhonda making in
the wwe
millions millions more money than she's
ever made
no no well she's she's getting paid to
pretend
so why the [ __ ] would you risk all that
and go back to ufc what do you think
about king velasquez you think he's
gonna stick with did you see
him he's good it's i mean he's a
masculine [ __ ]
he put that mask on and with the mexican
lucha leaving a [ __ ] crew
dude he could be huge he said he loves
you he could be huge
dude he was doing flips and [ __ ] and
yeah yeah
with his legs